[people screaming]
[alarm wailing]
It ends here, King Lhoga!
Aah!
[roars]
[glass shattering]
King Lhoga's Hyper-Flame
is too strong!
There's only one way
I can defeat him.
Battleman X!
Red Diamond Scorpion Tail:
activate!
Now you'll see what true power--
- Hey, whoa, whoa.
- What?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Is that your dick?
- What?
What the hell else
would I be talk--
I'm saying is that,
right there, between your legs.
- Is that your dick?
- No.
It's my Red Diamond
Scorpion Tail!
Uh, I don't know, man.
- It looks a lot like a dick.
- What?
It's not really cool to whip out
your dick while were fighting,
or whatever.
It's not a dick.
Watch this.
[grunting]
[explosion]
[people screaming]
- See?
- Oh, okay.
If anything, I'm more convinced
it's a dick now.
No. It's an energy weapon.
[grunting]
Excuse me.
[whistles]
Whoa, you are really
consumed with that dick.
Sorry, there's a short
refractory period
between blasts.
Please don't say refractory.
Quit stalling and meet
your fate, King Lhoga!
Red Diamond Scorpion Tail:
enter Mega Mode 9!
Wow, that is the most dick-like
thing I've ever seen,
and I've fought Dickulon.
Look, I think
I'm just gonna go, okay?
The city is safe once again.
King Lhoga has been defeated
by Battleman X.
Okay, all right,
I'm sorry, excuse me.
For the record,
uh, I wasn't defeated.
I'm leaving
because it got weird.